from his own end zone
he waited too long and down he goes and
it's going to be a safety
did the ball get out though I think it
might have been recovered by Tennessee
I'd pass rush was a factor he gets his
arm
it's a fumble it's picked up it's
fumbled again at the line did the
offensive lineman get out of the end
zone was his knee down
and just turns right there at six means
the edge Rutgers have a tough time
getting there try a draw playing the
ball is out Georgia's got it
Terry and Ingram Dawkins
if it's done by 88
blows it up reaches from behind and
makes the play that's two forced fumbles
didn't we say he'd be a factor he is he
is
now the crowd is really wound up I think
he's being a little humble in that
assessment but they're both outstanding
and Jalen Carter so is he yeah
I mean he's just so quick off the ball
and he's going to win one-on-one battles
all the time just goes right by the
guard Cole Smith
too quick too powerful
they'll run it with Dante Smith and
Dante Smith has planted for a loss of a
couple
you're going to see this tackle pull
okay now watch Carter as he pulls follow
him right there see see how he follows
them that is spectacular tackle leaves
you follow him because you know he's
pulling for a reason a little bit of a
jersey grab right there
you're talking about a physical talent
in jail and Carter that's going to be a
top 10 pick in the NFL
that number 18 became famous
[Applause]
now for LSU since that year
Josh Williams dropped for a loss by
Jalen Carter
dalen Daniels would like to but Jalen
Carter's got him again and I wonder if
Kirby Smart will dare take a timeout
here did you see that at the end of the
play and lifted him up with one hand
that draftable player might even include
those guys but look at him fight through
two people and then watch this lift him
up with one hand oh my goodness oh